rhinos are going extinct a race against
time to save the Rhinos poachers
Massacre rhinos for their horns some are
carved into ornaments some are ground up
and sold for medicine just one of these
can sell for as much as 300 thousand
dollars
it's no wonder around 500 rhinos have
been slain by poachers in South Africa
so far this year
poaching determined to get business the
upcoming documentary horn maker features
entrepreneur Matt Markus who says he has
a solution to poaching create more rhino
horns artificial horn then flood the
market with that one way to devalue
something is actually create a lot of it
there'd be no incentives to poach
animals that's correct
and when things are abundant people
don't fight kill or steal South Africa
once tried something similar for 20
years they made it legal to own rhinos
and sell their horns farmers would put
the Rhinos to sleep with tranquilizer
darts sawed off their horns and sell the
horn because this was legal
Rhino farmers had an incentive to breed
rhinos and protect them the Rhino
population quadrupled
but then South Africa banned sales of
rhino horn again poaching went down no I
went up I went up by a thousands of
percent and the fear is that the Rhino
could be extinct within 10 years so
Marcus's idea artificial horn might save
the Rhino I would think the people who
want to preserve wildlife would love
this idea
I would think they'd love it too but no
all these environmental groups hate his
idea this is dangerous
what they're doing is absolutely
dangerous for Ryan and their survival
this is greenwashing an illegal activity
legal sales say environmental groups
might increase Rhino killing that
happened once with elephants it started
up new carving industry in China that
had been dormant for four decades it
needs to be long enough to bring the
prices down and then people say there's
no money in coaching so the problem is
that people still Percy animals as
commodities as natural resources rollers
you know so you're all they haven't had
eggs
that's a commodity from a chicken what's
wrong
over there are we really going to now
just farm every single animal on this
planet so we can can endlessly continue
supplying this like bloodlust and thirst
of people to consume wildlife products
if that's what it takes to preserve the
animals your bans have failed last year
can you burned a hundred tons of
confiscated elephants and rhinos
poaching is up a thousand Park Rangers
have been killed by poachers your band
is cruel to people and animals the
increase in poaching is a direct
responsibility of the folks in China and
Vietnam that are pushing this product
onto innocent consumers so sell them a
substitute cheap product and this will
stop you people have your head in the
sand but a cheap product that doesn't
happen organizations like mine are
partnering with the Vietnamese
government to reduce demand for rhino
horn and falen know we're succeeding
that's the thing so we've reached about
40 million Vietnamese in the last three
years reach means 40 million people
supposedly saw her public relations
campaign please self assess my family
from rhino poachers a Humane Society
survey found videos like this persuaded
many people that rhino horns have no
medical value stop use rhino horn
it cannot make you healthy so what
people are still poaching the rhinos so
it takes time it takes time for that
trickle-down effect it's fine if
environmental groups try to convince
people not to buy rhino horn but their
hostility to capitalism makes them blind
to better ideas like artificial horn and
South Africa's new plan to legalize horn
sales again South Africa's going against
the international body that's fighting
to protect rhinos so what these
international bodies are stupid no a
little bit there are folks like me that
then work to pass these restrictions but
it's like the drug war you can ban a but
if there's money to be made the poachers
are still going to kill the animal
prohibition should have taught us that
when something's valuable banning its
consumption leads to law breaking and
killing nobody kills anybody any more
for beer or wine or scotch when you're
talking about beer or wine or Scotch you
don't have lives on the line live some
of the people who were killed by Al
Capone well of course but you know he
was a criminal and you have criminal
networks here in criminal because
alcohol was illegal yeah I mean this is
this is a endless argument we can't live
in a lawless society a free society is
not a lawless society markets are not
lawless legal rhino farming or selling
fake corn could save endangered animals
but the environmental groups just can't
see them
you